it is economically rational for women to
try as hard as possible to be thin and
each of their activities not only keeps
them fit but provides it and that is a
tragedy
this is the secret economics of thinness
across the developed world the rich
people are the thinner they tend to be
this relationship though is driven
almost entirely by women
this chart shows the share of men and
women in France that are classified as
obese and their income levels obese
women tend to earn far less than their
thin appears but obese men and thin men
tend to earn about the same
seems true in America and in South Korea
obese men tend to earn more than nothing
appears but in each of these countries
richer women are much more likely to be
thin than poorer ones in fact the
correlation is so strong that for an
obese woman of average height losing 65
pounds could have the same impact on her
wages as gaining a master's degree
why is this
traditionally people have believed that
poverty which can make it difficult to
access healthy foods or find time to
exercise can explain why in general poor
people are more likely to be obese but
those arguments should apply equally to
both men and women and they don't
so perhaps the causality runs the other
way it is being thin that helps women to
become rich
in many ways thinness is an economic
Pursuit
think of the time and money that women
invest in trying to eat healthily or
attending exercise classes
there while social attitudes towards
weight may have shifted in recent
decades the economic reality so far has
not
[Music]
[Applause]